The doctor is Haytam
Kallab, 27 years old, a general physician. I work in the emergency room of
Nasser Hospital. In case of emergency, our work is divided into two
groups, which pays 24 hours with 24
hours of
rest. This war is different from previous wars, a
complete difference, first of all, from the number of
casualties and the quantity
coming to
Nasser Hospital, the nature of the cases that we came from.
Frightening degrees of burns, including loss and lacerations of organs, especially the
limbs, in many cases,
for example, in previous wars in particular, and with these huge
numbers, the largest percentages that I received
were either children or women.
Bombing any hospital is immoral, so imagine
the pressure that would occur at any possible moment.  Do you think that you
might be diminished from your workplace or the performance of your profession,
especially if your profession is humanitarian, especially in an ambulance in
front of or inside Nasser Hospital? The ambulance was
inside, and in fact, I was at the head of my
work. It was a majestic sight, especially when you see your
colleagues who are being transported sitting in the casualties
being transported in the casualties.  You suddenly find them with the
same injuries that happen to those who work
in the emergency. To be safe, especially during wars, or perhaps in Gaza in
particular, we see things that the
human mind cannot tolerate. Perhaps the most difficult case I have ever experienced
was a mother carrying her child, a dead child,
holding the father of her child while her legs were completely dislodged, and
of course there were more than  She was injured and needs to enter the
red station, meaning the station. I don’t
know whether to take her son away from her or whether to let her son in. I couldn’t honestly
take her son from her, and honesty also
affected the situation, so
I wanted to follow up with her. I mean, I heard her
talking. I wish I had died before my leg was cut off.